Now, let's make this a little bit more challenging. Sometimes, there might be
two radicals in your equation. If there are two radicals, it's best to separate
them, so one is on each side of this equals sign. We've seen adding numbers and
fractions to both sides of an equation. Well, we can do the same with a
radical. We'll just add it on the left, and add it on the right. On the left,
we'll just have 2 root x. And on the right hand side, we'll have the square
root of 3x plus 9. Now I definitely think you're at a position to solve this
equation. Think about what you could do to both sides of the equation to
eliminate the radical symbol. Then when you think you've solved for x, type
your answer here. Again, if there's no solution, I want you to type ns. Good
luck on this one.